LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them,
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do it.
And today we're going
to do exactly that.
So welcome to this episode
of "Coffee with a Googler."
And one of the things that we've
been doing since we started
the show is we've been
asking about which
Googlers you'd
like to speak with,
which Googlers you'd like me
to have a conversation with,
and what kind of topics
we could talk about.
And the first name that
came up was Colt McAnlis.
He's also the name that
came up the most often.
So Colt, you're finally with us.
Thank you.
Congratulations.
COLT MCANLIS: Thank you.
So I just want to make
sure that this is clear.
I want to make sure
I understand this.
I outranked Larry
Page to be here.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Your page rank is
higher than Larry Page's rank.
COLT MCANLIS: Thank you,
community, for voting me here.
I mean, what does Larry
have to talk about?
LAURENCE MORONEY: I don't know.
I will talk about
it with him someday,
and we'll see what
he has to say.
And I'd love to hear what
he has to say about you.
COLT MCANLIS: You shouldn't
probably ask him about me.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'll give
it a try and we'll see.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So Colt, you're
a developer advocate
here at Google.
And tell us, what is a developer
advocate and what do they do?
COLT MCANLIS: Well, it's this
really weird hybrid role,
right?
I mean, we're all very
technically inclined people
who know very technical stuff.
But in reality, we've
got to spit out content.
We're kind of like
talking sock puppets.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Indeed.
COLT MCANLIS: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: To
be sure, to be sure.
COLT MCANLIS: I feel
for Kermit the Frog.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes, me too.
I think he's angry because
he's got your hand up his butt.
COLT MCANLIS: Well,
tell me, Laurence.
What do you think about
the developer advocacy role
and how you approach it's craft?
LAURENCE MORONEY: You
know, one of the ways
that I like to approach it
is really enriching people
through video.
I have this show
where I'm a host,
and I call it "Coffee
with a Googler."
Wait, what?
So Colt is a developer
advocate here at Google.
And there's lots of
ways that one can
be an advocate for developers.
And Colt, you've got
some pretty unique stuff
that you've been working on.
Can you tell us about it?
COLT MCANLIS: You
know, I really try
to find the stuff that
helps developers that's
not part of our normal rigor.
So we talk about APIs a lot.
We talk about the
platform a lot.
We talk about how the
new stuff is coming out.
But there's a lot of
things that are just
core and fundamental to making
and building great applications
that kind of fall through
the cracks, that no one else
is really covering.
And to be honest, I really like
to focus a lot of my advocacy
in those rare areas.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Like
I know some examples.
You've been working on the
"Compressor Head" and "Android
Performance Patterns."
Tell us about "Compressor Head."
I mean, I keep hearing there's
this TV show out there.
And did you get
the idea from them,
or did they get
the idea from you,
those folks in Silicon Valley?
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, so
"Compressor Head," for those
who may not have seen it,
is a show about compression
that we do on the Google
Developers channel.
And effectively, it's me trying
to distill these really crazy
complex algorithms that
drive everything we
do in computers now-- like every
bit you see on a mobile device
has been compressed
at this point--
and distill the algorithms down.
Because for some reason, the
art and science of compression
really has fallen away from
the education that we've done.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now,
some people might say that
with bandwidth getting
increasingly cheaper
and storage getting increasingly
cheaper, compression
isn't really that important.
What would you think about that?
COLT MCANLIS: I
wholeheartedly challenge that.
You have to remember that
software and data is a gas,
right?
It will grow to fill whatever
container we put it in.
And we're going through
this great industrial boom
right now where hardware
costs are coming down.
But that is not something that's
going to continue indefinitely.
If you watch the
way that computing
has worked over
the past 50 years,
you end up with these
booms and busts.
You get a huge jump
in processing power.
And then that will
level off for a while
until a new technology
comes around
and you get a huge one again.
And we're seeing that
with data right now.
And you also have to remember
that while our data centers are
getting larger and where we
host our content gets larger,
the medium between the
cell tower and your phone
is not growing at
that same rate.
I mean, you have to remember
that almost half of America
is still on a 2G network.
Worldwide, 2G is like
the king's knees.
That's the best they
can get, especially
for the next 5 billion humans
that are coming online.
They're not going to
be on 4G LTE networks.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Absolutely.
COLT MCANLIS: If
you're someone that's
trying to create a strategy
around getting the most
users to your content, trying
to build an ecosystem that's
data driven in their
social networks
for these next 5
billion users, you
can't rely on data centers
and all these other hardware.
You have to compress your data.
We talk a little bit
about this in the show.
There's a couple
different spots where
we talk about these things.
In fact, I think we
have the clip of it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We
have a clip, yeah.
Jimmy, can you run the clip?
COLT MCANLIS: The move-to-front
algorithm is pretty simple.
For each symbol we read,
we write its output buffer
position, and then move it
to the front of our buffer.
Now, for example, if
we input the letter N,
that sits at position 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12,
13, 14.
So we write that to
our output stream.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it's
a pretty complex subject,
and you're teaching
it quite simply.
Is that the theme of the show?
Is that how you do it?
COLT MCANLIS: That's
exactly what it was.
I mean, we're using
Lego blocks in there.
The whole concept
came from, how do we
take this really complex
idea and break it down
to be able to teach it with
sticky notes and Play-Doh
and Lego blocks?
Because we've got kids,
and we're constantly
teaching things to kids.
And so I figured if this method
works on three-year-olds,
obviously it'll work on
programmers-- no offense.
So yeah, that's
the whole gimmick.
That's the whole
point of the show.
How complex can we
get from an algorithm
and how can we teach it with
Play-Doh and sticky notes?
LAURENCE MORONEY: So now as
well as "Compressor Head,"
you talk a lot
about performance.
And you have your
perfmatters hashtag
and your "Android
Performance Patterns" show.
And I think you've just finished
up another season of that.
Tell us about it.
COLT MCANLIS: So "Android
Performance Patterns"
is, again, one of those
gap filling initiatives.
Everyone has to care
about performance.
If you're shipping
an application,
users leave feedback about
bad performing applications
in a negative manner three
times more than anything else
in your app, more than if they
don't like your social media
is laid out, or they
don't like how long it
takes to download something,
or just your UI is bad.
That's like crickets.
However, if you're slow,
or if it feels laggy,
man, people just hate it.
It's just the truth
of the industry.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
negative reviews, I mean,
everybody wants to avoid that.
COLT MCANLIS: Exactly.
And you can't fix that with
chiming back with people.
You just have to fundamentally
fix that at your level.
And "Android
Performance Patterns"
is built around that gap.
Because you've got
the documentation,
which tells you how to use
the API and what it does.
But then you really
don't have anything past
that to tell you the right way
to use it for your performance
cases across all the
devices in our ecosystem.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
COLT MCANLIS: Because
what works on a high end
Android device may not
work on a low end one
or on a different device type
or form factor or something.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So what are
the typical performance gotchas
that people have that you might
help them avoid with the show?
COLT MCANLIS: So there's three
big pillars of performance
that we like to talk about.
So you can either have rendering
problems-- so for example,
overdrawing too many pixels
on the screen at one time.
So this means you're going to be
wasting GPU and CPU cycle time.
We've also got memory problems.
So this is the quintessential
programmer issue--
using too many memories, kicking
off garbage collection events.
In fact, I think we actually
have a clip of that.
We have a clip of that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, can we
run the clip please, Jimmy?
COLT MCANLIS: Even though
you're in a managed memory
environment,
improperly using memory
can still kick off a load
of performance problems.
And allocating too many
objects in a short time frame
is a clear problem that
you should be aware of.
You have to remember that
the memory heap in Android
is segmented up
into separate spaces
based upon what type of
allocation is occurring.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, so in
that scene, we saw memory.
And earlier, we were
talking about graphics.
And the third one--
is it battery?
COLT MCANLIS:
Battery, that's right.
I gotta tell you,
one of the things
that we all hate with our
mobile devices right now is
you can't get through a day
without needing to recharge.
I mean, you're doing cool stuff,
and you need to get it done.
But the fact is
that most developers
aren't thinking enough about
how to optimize their battery
performance.
And we talk a great
deal about the things
that developers need
to do to keep users'
batteries lasting longer.
And I think we all
benefit from that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Absolutely.
That's more than just negative
reviews and avoiding them.
That's actually making
someone's life a little better.
COLT MCANLIS: It's a
little karma, really.
I mean, as a developer, you
want to get that good karma.
It's doing the right thing.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Speaking of karma,
I keep hearing about
this Perf Like a Pirate.
I mean, there's good pirates,
and there's bad pirates.
And this seems to be
one of the good pirates.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So what's this
whole Perf Like a Pirate thing?
I've always wanted to go, arr.
So now I get to.
COLT MCANLIS: (PIRATE
VOICE) Yar, matey.
You've got to do it
in the right voice.
It's a little between Irish
leprechaun and British weirdo.
I don't know.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That
sounds a lot like me.
COLT MCANLIS: Comment
in the section.
So Perf Like a
Pirate was an event
that we started a
year before last.
We ended up wanting to do
this event on performance
for HTML5 Users Group in
San Francisco, SFHTML5.
And just weird dice roll that
the event actually happened
on Talk Like a Pirate Day.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yar, I see.
COLT MCANLIS: And no one
really thought about it.
It was kind of in the
back of everyone's mind.
And I was like, you know what?
We've got to do
something with this.
And so I gave my
entire talk in pirate.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
COLT MCANLIS: And so for like
the next six to eight months,
every time I would go to
a conference or something,
someone would walk by me and
be like, yar matey, do we
be talking about performance,
which was fantastic,
because I'm like, we've
got to do this again.
So we did it again last year.
I got a huge turnout,
another great set of people.
And so it's just
kind of really cool
to take this really mundane
topic like performance
that makes everyone's eyes
roll back in their head
and have fun with it.
And really more,
it's like to me,
that's the essence of what we
do as developer advocates is
take these really crazy,
insane things and make them
fun to learn about and fun
to bring together and change
the way we do our development.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Well, it certainly
has been fun having
you here today, Colt.
Thank you so much for coming.
And thanks everybody
for watching this far.
As always, we're on the
Google Developers channel.
I'm Laurence Moroney.
You can see my link underneath.
And Colt McAnlis, you can
see his link there too.
So please subscribe to
the Google Developers
channel for more shows,
including "Compressor Head"
and including Perf
Like a Pirate-- well,
not Perf Like a
Pirate, Perfmatters,
and "Android
Performance Patterns."
And if you've any other
questions for Colt or for me
or any other Googlers that you'd
like to chat with, maybe even
Larry Page himself, please
put it in the comments below.
Thanks, everybody.
[MUSIC PLAYING]